Speaker 1: . I want to do a little bit of
an update on a story.
There is a news story here, but there also
isn't in the sense that we already had the
facts about the real covid mortality and fatality
rate in the state of New York.
There are a bunch of different headlines now
which say things like New York governor acknowledges
nearly 12000 more covid fatality fatalities
then publicized by Andrew Cuomo.
And the story goes.
New York Governor Kathy Hochul promised more
government transparency on her first day in
office.
And by day's end, her administration had quietly
delivered it by acknowledging nearly 12000
more deaths in the state from covid-19 than
had been publicized by her predecessor, Andrew
Cuomo.
New York now reports nearly fifty five, four
hundred based on death certificate.
See, up from 43, 7400 that Cuomo had reported
to the public as of Monday, his last name
in office, we are now releasing more data
than had been released before publicly.
So people know the nursing home deaths and
hospital deaths are consistent with what's
being displayed by the CDC.
Got a bunch of emails from people saying,
David, I don't understand.
I looked on World Committers and the CDC website.
Nothing changed.
And that's exactly right.
The scandal here was that the Cuomo administration
was not acknowledging roughly these 10 to
12, what was 10 now is known to be 12000 covid
deaths.
But the CDC was always acknowledging them.
And websites like World Committers and others
are based on CDC data.
So this is more of a political story than
it is a WOA.
There's actually 12000 more people that died.
We knew about that and we reported it feels
like it's been a couple of months since we
learned of that.
Now, when it comes to Andrew Cuomo, what is
even worse, the covid stuff or the sexual
harassment stuff?
I think at the macro level, not to diminish
what Andrew Cuomo has been credibly accused
of based on a report.
I think that the covid stuff, without a doubt
has been worse.
But this is not actually new information.
It's just that it's now being acknowledged
formally by the state.
Good to see the new governor acknowledge it.
At the same time, there's an aspect of this
that seems very political in the sense that
the data was already out there.
We covered it months ago.
This sort of is like a get out of jail free
card for everybody else in the executive branch.
And it's probably legitimate to say, really,
this is Andrew Cuomo.
They threw Cuomo out, Cuomo gets the blame.
And now Kathy Hochul or is it Hochul?
I actually don't know how to pronounce acknowledges
it.
And it's sort of like, hey, everything's good
now.
While the truth is, it's very hard to imagine
that more people within the administration
of the state government of New York didn't
know that this was going on.
So there's an aspect of this that feels like
this is the perfect timing to just acknowledge
it and move on and try to avoid any other
consequences for anybody now that Cuomo is
gone and the numbers match the CDC.
But in some sense, it's good that they have
now said, yes, this is the real number of
deaths here in the state of New York.
Do you think that this has any importance
beyond just quietly putting it out there so
that now they can move on and try to prevent
anybody else from having any kind of consequence
as a result?
Let me know.
But the data is not new and it seems to me
like a pretty brazen act of say it, sweep
it under the rug, and then if it ever comes
up again, say that was on Cuomo and Cuomo
is now gone.
We've taken care of the problem.
Everybody's gotten the consequence they deserve.
Let me know.
We'll be covering this more on our Instagram
where you can find us at The David Pakman
Show.
Find me on Instagram as well, David at David
Pakman.